peinlich so lang alu am letzten samstag
gab es zwei große nachrichten ereignisse
zum einen die größte demonstration in
deutschland seit den anti irakkrieg
protesten 2003 mit 242.000 teilnehmern
in berlin
zum anderen gab es noch die
kandidatenkür in einem rechtsradikalen
provinz vereinen thüringen mit 297
teilnehmern
ich habe die teilnehmerzahlen mal
grafisch gegenübergestellt
hier die größte demo in deutschland seit
15 jahren hier
der fdp parteitag
sie erkennen dass vielleicht nicht
sofort deswegen habe ich es markiert
ich rechne das mal kurz nach doch bei
der demo waren mehr das heute journal
hat dann gesagt ist beides gleich
wichtig bekommt jeweils drei minuten
sendezeit
das heißt um in den zdf-nachrichten eine
sende sekunde zu bekommen
brauchte man letzten samstag entweder
1367 demokraten oder 1,7 nazis
warum ist das so ich glaube weil die
medien ein herz für minderheiten haben
leider für die falschen
kennen sie die sommerinterviews mit
spitzenpolitikern diesen sommer ging es
da eine stunde und 18 minuten um flucht
asyl und migration
und jetzt raten sie mal wie lange über
bildung gesprochen wurde
18 sekunden ich persönlich finde das
empörend
warum wird dem thema bildung in
deutschland so viel raum gegeben
das sind 18 sekunden in denen man sich
auch mit etwas wichtigem hätte
auseinandersetzen können migration zum
beispiel
aber es gab natürlich auch themen die
wirklich erschöpfend behandelt wurden
gesundheit und pflege
26 sekunden auch in talkshows werden
minderheiten gehört große gruppen er
nicht wenn man zu den 1,5 millionen
alleinerziehenden in deutschland gehört
wird man seltener eingeladen als wenn
man den den vereinen der 3 arschlöcher
gründet aber ich weiß jetzt auch nicht
was das mit der fdp zu tun haben viele
medien wollen einfach immer noch mit
rechtsradikalen reden wie sinnvoll das
ist hat fußballspieler eric cantona
schon mal wunderbar auf den punkt
gebracht er hat gesagt mit rassisten
diskutieren das ist wie mit einer taube
schach spielen egal wie gut du bist
egal wie sehr du dich anstrengen am ende
wird die taube auf spielfeld kacken
alles umschmeißen und umher stolzieren
als hätte sie gewonnen
[Musik]